so you may have heard the rumors and
whether or not you love it or hate it
you gotta admit it's a little strange
alright so Keanu Reeves has come out and
said but he also said the Wachowski
brothers or the with Chow skis or
whatever they are now came to him with
two finished scripts for the matrix four
and five which will feature neo which I
personally find really strange for
reasons including but not limited to
I thought the Matrix movies were done
with revolutions and yeah revolutions
ended with kind of an open ending which
I personally saw is trivializing the
whole thing and - judging by the shitty
matrix MMO do you remember the matrix
MMO and nobody else does either ki might
that's it
I thought the matrix franchise itself
was just dead so for the first movie
gotta say it is good revolutionary all
that good m3 and this is a spoiler
warning for people who haven't seen the
Matrix Revolutions if you have not seen
the Matrix Revolutions god bless you for
having the matrix in your head is still
awesome neo died at the end so how are
they gonna have dead Theodore Logan in
the new ones I want this to be really
cool but as it stands it just looks like
your standard well it was great but no
one takes it seriously anymore so let's
just bleed it dry
let's bleed the dead franchise more dead
if you're gonna take advice or look on
an example of how to keep a franchise
alive in the people's minds don't take
it from SAW just saying and it said that
these new Matrix movies will be as
revolutionary as the first one India
it's in 3d I really hope the 3d is not
the thing that they're talking about
when they talk about revolutionary
because I don't want to burst any
bubbles but it's been done in fact not
only has it been done but it's been so
crammed down our throats you get the
idea but two new Matrix movies good idea
bad idea absolute I gave you
guys the final word comment below let me
know and as always if you like what
you've seen here and you want to see
more click right here to see more I know
come through